now the latest on last week's midterms
we now know who will control the U.S
Senate for the next two years after a
very lengthy vote count CBS News
projects that Senator Catherine Cortez
masto was re-elected in Nevada so that
gives Democrats and their independent
allies at least at least 50 seats enough
to keep control with the potential
tie-breaking vote from vice president
Kamala Harris control of the house
remains still unclear today with fewer
than a dozen seats still undecided
Nicole killing is on Capitol Hill with
the latest on this story good morning to
you Nicole so what are you hearing about
what will happen now
well Gail CBS News estimates that
Republicans are favored to win a narrow
majority in the house but Democrats
still believe they have a slim path to
Victory
[Applause]
in a rousing rally Nevada senator
Catherine Cortez masto celebrated after
clinching a second term when the
national pundits said I couldn't win
I knew Nevada would prove them wrong
her victory over Republican Adam laxalt
gave Democrats a one-seat edge to claim
the majority in the U.S Senate hoping to
build on the party's agenda we can do
more that benefit the American people
that have that help average families
Democrats now have 50 seats in the
chamber compared to 49 held by
Republicans with one key outstanding
race in Georgia that goes to a runoff
next month in the house both parties
remain shy of the 218-seat threshold to
gain control speaker Nancy Pelosi said
she would wait until after the election
to announce if she'll run again for
leadership and criticize GOP leader
Kevin McCarthy's presumptive bid to take
over the gavel no I don't think he has
it but that's up to his own people new
members arriving for orientation in
Washington were filled with suspense
we're all just refreshing our phones
constantly to see who might have a slim
Edge the finger pointing only
intensifying after a red wave failed to
materialize those who are most closely
aligned with the former president did
underperformed those who are talking
about the future who have managed their
states well they over performed the
American people want ideas they want a
future this is happening as former vice
president Mike Pence sitched down for a
series of interviews about his new book
that in part grapples with former
president Trump's role in the January
6th Insurrection I mean the president's
words were Reckless
it was clear he decided to be part of
the problem
as the Republican Party continues to
debate the former president's impact on
the midterms he appears to be moving
full steam ahead for 2024. Trump
advisors tell CBS News he intends to
launch his campaign with an announcement
from his Mar-A-Lago home Tuesday Tony
we will be following that as well Nicole
thank you very much